bonsoir mona après le premier tour une
passe d'armes entre gère darmanin et
eric dupond moretti
une nouvelle si j'ose me racontez nous
mais on peut dire que les lendemains de
défaite ne sont jamais simples pour
certains l'altercation se passe peu
avant le conseil des ministres entre le
premier flic de france et l'ancien ténor
du barreau sur un sujet très récent et
les régionales le garde des sceaux a
reproché à son collègue d'avoir
chaleureusement félicité xavier bertrand
qui est arrivé en tête dans la région
hôte france région dans laquelle dupond
moretti était également candidat écouter
dharmanand vous connaissez mon estime
pour xavier bertrand il a été récompensé
pour son bilan
j'appelle sans difficulté à voter pour
lui c'est un ami vous le savez et je
suis un homme de droite j'ai toujours
été clair là dessus le président le sait
la majorité le sait je ne trahis
personne elle défaite difficile à avaler
selon dupont moretti c'est une trahison
de la part de dharmanand je cite
dupond-moretti félicité xavier bertrand
pour son bilan
c'est une trahison tu ne peux pas
marcher sur tes collègues c'est une
question de loyauté
et mona lagarde le garde des sceaux
aurait été particulièrement touché par
sa défaite aux élections régionales
oui c'est pas ni après l'annoncé des
résultats et eric dupond-moretti n'a pas
fait de déclarations il aura fallu
attendre deux jours pour qu'enfin ils
tweetent je voterai sans état d'âme
pour xavier bertrand mais souvenez vous
et ce n'est pas la première fois que les
deux hommes s'affrontent il ya quelques
mois le ministre de la justice indiqué
qu'il n'utiliserait jamais le terne
sauvages les termes employés par gérald
darmanin
et ce n'est pas la seule altercation
avant le conseil des ministres von ah
oui ça continue ce n'est pas la seule
avant le conseil des ministres ce fut au
tour de la ministre du travail elisabeth
bande de s'en prendre à barbara pompili
la ministre de la transition écologique
elisabeth bornes elle lui aurait
reproché d'avoir salué la décision du
conseil d'état sur la suspension des
nouvelles règles de calcul de
l'assurance chômage un acte qui aurait
aidé plus fortement à la ministre du
travail
et c'est à ce moment que le chef de
l'état mona a sifflé la fin de la
récréation
oui arrivé après cette énième
altercation
emmanuel macron est arrivé dans un
climat quelque peu électrique il a remis
les pendules à l'heure notamment sur
cette fameuse question de l'assurance
chômage en déclarant que féliciter la
décision du conseil d'état s'est aussi
inacceptable que déloyale en tout cas ça
le mérite d'être clair pour barbara
pompili en tout cas l'ambiance qui règne
au sein de l'exécutif relance une
nouvelle loi une nouvelle fois pardon
les rumeurs d'un possible remaniement
cet été avec un emmanuel macron qui veut
avoir le meilleur casting pour aborder
la présidentielle d'ici quelques mois
car le chef de l'état le sait il doit
avoir une équipe solide et soudée pour
pouvoir espérer fédérer et rassembler
les français autour de lui
merci monaco dès lors en direct de la
place beauvau merci à vous